Oh  it's like the fantasy you always have as  a kid everywhere is an amazing shot an  amazing character  it's about the humanity of it which just  makes the whole thing so real pretty  Archer  or your hearts beating and you're  actually in this situation you get  something very genuine that you can the  plant  you'll actually compose shots that if we  were on a green screen set you just  wouldn't have known we're available  fresh is so high we're making a film  that's right touching my favorite movie  of all time but then if you're too  respectful of it that you didn't do  anything new or different take a risk  then what are you bringing to the table  sweet coast and shut down there  this is really where a film crew like  this really comes into the right  got kids when you were four years old  group will star wars figures it's a bit  like just being that kid again so they  like  may the force be with us